Today, I want to talk about some of the things that I did...
...to improve my experience on social media.
And I did that by both reducing my time on there,...
...and also making a few changes to make it more positive,...
...so that I don't get that sinking feeling of failure.
Social media completely altered the way pretty much all of us interact and see the world.
I've struggled with social media in the past.
At times it has messed with my self-esteem, and distorted my perception of reality,...
...and the lives that people lead.
It can be addicting, but it doesn't have to be that way.
Social media can be a series of tools.
Tools, by the way, that have allowed me to lead a life that I really enjoy,...
...that I'm super lucky to have.
And honestly, it's an opportunity to practice intentional living.
So, let's dive in.
Remove the fluff.
The first thing to think about here is that your time and attention are really valuable.
In fact, it's the most valuable resource that you have.
Why else would advertisers spend hundreds of billions of dollars a year...
...to try and get in front of you?